Okay,
now now down to cognitive ability.
Well,
how can you conceptualize intelligence?
this is a major problem because your
initial conceptualization determines in
part the strategies that you're going to
use to investigate intelligence and when
you say when you,
when you pair a sentence down to what is
intelligence,
the sentence is problematic because part
of it is a question about if and how
such a thing might manifest itself in
the world.
So there's a fact out there that are set
of facts that corresponds to
intelligence,
but the other problem is,
well,
what do you mean when you say
intelligence?
And you kind of have to nail that down.
If you're going to have a conversation
about intelligence that doesn't go
entirely astray and so you've got a,
you've got a definitional problem as
well as an empirical problem.
And so there have been,
and this was especially true in the 19
nineties,
people have been studying intelligence
Iq intelligence since the 19 twenties
and,
and it's a very well established branch
of psychology.
One of the things I have to tell you
about Iq research is that if you don't
buy Iq research,
you might as well throw away all the
rest of psychology and the reason for
that is that
the psychologists,
first of all,
who developed intelligence testing were
among the early psychologists who
instantiated the statistical techniques
that all psychologists use to verify and
test all of their hypotheses.
So you ended up throwing the baby out
with the bathwater and the ICU.
People have defined intelligence in a
more stringent,
stringent and accurate way than we've
been able to define almost any other
psychological construct.
And so if you toss out the one that's
most well defined,
then you're kind of stuck with the
problem of what are you going to do with
all the ones that you have leftover that
are nowhere near as well defined or as
well measured,
or as or as or.
Or who's predictive.
Validity is much less than it has been
demonstrated with much less vigor and
clarity anyways.
Despite all that.
People have posited a number of
different intelligences and reasonably
so because there's.
If you think of intelligence as that
which might move you forward
successfully in the world,
obviously there's a fair number of
phenomena that are associated with
individuals that might fit into that
category,
so we have people have made these
distinctions.
Bob Sternberg,
for example,
is distinguished between practical
versus analytical intelligence and he
kind of thinks of practical as like
street smarts and has attempted to
dissociate that from the kind of
analytical intelligence that that
characterizes more straight Iq research.
I don't think he's done it successfully
as well at all and since the 19
nineties,
interest in his practical intelligence
has declined precipitously because when
it is matched head to head with standard
Iq intelligence,
the Iq intelligence seats up pull the
variability.
What's really happened as far as I can
tell so far is that when we're trying to
predict people's course through life,
Iq does a very good job and then one of
the traits does a very good job as well,
which is conscientiousness,
but it doesn't do as good a job as Iq.
Now,
that partly might be because we can't
measure conscientiousness very well.
We're stuck with self reports or maybe I
could gather peer reports about you or I
could gather your parents reports about
your teachers reports and each of those
seems to pick up a little bit more of
the pattern because you know yourself,
but other people know you differently
than you know yourself and there's still
some accuracy in that.
You can get multiple rater reports of
something like conscientiousness and
that'll up.
It's predictive validity,
but in the final analysis,
the best you seem to be able to deal
with conscientiousness is about a point
four correlation with longterm
performance.
Whereas with Iq in complex jobs,
you can probably get point five and
maybe point six and so point five is 25
percent of the variance.
You got a square it point six is 30
percent,
36 percent of the variance and point
four is 16 percent of the variance.
So even at the low end,
let's say high end for conscientiousness
is point four or 16 percent.
Low End for Iq is point five or 25
percent low end estimates of Iq make it
one and a half times more powerful than
the high end estimates of
conscientiousness and I think that's
about right.
You'd think,
why do we even have to debate this and
because it's so bloody obvious to me
that intelligence is a major predictor
of life success.
I mean you people,
I've measured the Iq of University of
Toronto people,
you know,
people in this room who have an Iq of
less than 120 are rare.
Well,
why?
Well smart people go to university now.
Is that actually a contentious
statement?
What shouldn't be a contentious
It's self evident.
Universities were actually set up so
that smart people could expand their
abilities.
That's why they were there.
And you're selected on the basis of
assessments that are essentially there
to assess something like intelligence.
Yes,
but that,
that will,
that is part of the controversy.
Is it reasonable?
And this is a measurement issue and
that's why we're.
That's why I've been instructing you to
some degree in psychometrics because we
actually know how to do this.
We know how to answer that question,
so let's take a look at how at how
intelligence has been assessed and why,
and then you can make up your own mind
anyways.
Here's some of the examples of other
forms of intelligence and so then the
question is,
well,
what does it mean to have a different
form of intelligence?
Would would form a and form b be
completely uncorrelated,
like extroversion,
say in neuroticism or would they be
slightly correlated or would they be
highly correlated and then you might
ask,
well,
how highly correlated did they have to
be before they're the same thing or how
uncorrelated did they have to be before
they're different things and actually
the answer to that comes down to
something like practical utility.
It's like,
imagine I'm trying to figure out how
well you'll do in university and I
measure one thing and it's correlated at
point seven with another thing I measure
about you.
Then I might say,
well,
are those two things the same or
different?
They're pretty highly correlated.
Your high in one means you're going to
be high in the other while,
so what is there any utility in
measuring both things and the way you
figure that out actually is you do it
statistically,
so we take the target,
which might be your performance across
university.
Then we say,
well,
can we predict your performance across
university better by using one variable
or two variables?
So we would enter them both into a
regression equation.
All a regression equation does.
It's quite simple,
so you're trying to predict the target
and the regression age regression
equation tells you how well you can
predict that target.
If you know another fact now,
then it gets a little complicated
because that's a correlation.
How well you can predict be with a well.
A regression will say how much you can
predict.
See if you know a and B or a and B and c
and d and e because you can use multiple
predictors and you can weight them.
So it might be two times a plus one
times b equals c,
and that's all a regression equation
does is just multiplication and
addition.
Very,
very straightforward.
And so two variables are sufficiently
different functionally if you can use
both of them simultaneously to predict
something of interest.
So again,
it's a tool like approach.
This is how the psychometricians do.
It is something real.
Well,
it's real.
If you can measure,
measure it,
it,
it helps you predict that's,
that's how it's defined.
So then you might say,
well,
are are there these multiple
intelligences?
Well,
the first question would be,
well,
what do you mean by are there?
And that answer to that would be,
well,
let's specify the question since we're
going to be scientific about it.
Let's predict how well people do in
university.
We'll start with the assumption that
intelligence,
if intelligence isn't associated with
university success,
then you're probably not talking about
intelligence.
Now you could argue that,
right?
Because you could say,
well,
intelligence has nothing to do with
university success,
but that's a definitional matter.
We'd have to agree to begin with.
Is it reasonable to start with the
presupposition that intelligence and
university success share something in
common?
Well,
I think you have to be daft to,
to deny that initial proposition.
Although you could,
because you could say it was privileged
or socioeconomic status or or or,
or any number of sociological phenomena
and some of those are obviously relevant
social class for example,
because you know,
if you're in a higher social class and
all things being equal,
intelligence included,
if you're in a higher social class,
you're more likely to go to university
then you are if you're in a lower social
class.
So there's other,
there's other factors that are going to
influence whether or not you do well in
university,
but we're going to assume that one of
them might be intelligence.
Well then you would ask,
well,
if you measured social intelligence,
so that's what do they call that?
Social Intelligence.
Now,
emotional intelligence,
which does not exist by the way.
Emotional intelligence,
moral intelligence,
linguistic musical,
logical,
mathematical,
spacial body,
kinesthetic,
interpersonal and intrapersonal.
All different forms of intelligence.
Okay,
so to answer the question of whether
they exist,
what you do first is pick a target
prediction of university performance.
Then you make a measure for each of
them.
Then you test to see if the measure
measured the same thing across multiple
instances within the same person.
That's a reliability tests because what
the hell good is your ruler.
If it stretches when you use it,
it has to measure the same thing
multiple times and then you would say,
okay,
we'll take all these different
intelligences measured the way we've
decided to measure them.
The first thing we'll do is see how
highly correlated they are because if
they're complete,
two of them are completely correlated.
Then you have one.
You don't have to because that's
virtually the definition of one.
Instead of two.
You can factor analyze them and see if
you can pull out what's common across
all of them.
That's another thing because then you
might say,
well,
intelligence is what's common across all
the measures of these intelligences.
It's a proposition.
It's not a fact.
You have to decide if you're going to
agree with it,
but that if you were going to do that,
you'd use a factor analysis.
You'd say,
well,
if someone was more likely to be
musical,
if they were also high in linguistic
ability and more likely to be logical
and mathematically inclined,
if they had a high spatial ability,
et Cetera,
then you'd be hypothesizing that there
was one factor behind all of those
manifestations that somehow similar and
maybe there wouldn't be,
and then you take all your measures and
you put them in something like a
multiple regression analysis and you'd
predict your target university
performance and then maybe you'd say,
well,
wait a minute.
Let's not just use university
performance.
Let's use junior high performance,
high school performance,
university performance and job success,
and then let's say that the only things
that predict success across all of those
categories and that are the same,
we're going to define as intelligence.
Well,
that's basically how you end up with Iq.
You could say that Iq is what's common
across all possible sets of of
intelligence tests.
Now people are going to debate that
because you still have to define what
constitutes a test,
but the way the psychometricians have
managed it and have taken care of this
at least to some degree,
is to say,
well,
we're going to.
We're not going to define everything
that we measure as intelligence,
so extroverted people are more socially
fluent.
We're going to call that intelligence.
No,
we're going to call that personality.
We're going to call that extroversion
and we're going to call stress
tolerance.
You could say,
well,
if you can tolerate more stress,
you're more intelligent.
It's like,
well,
no,
that isn't how we've defined it.
We're going to define that as being
lower in neuroticism.
If you're cooperative,
you're more intelligent.
That's emotional intelligence.
Well,
what you're less intelligent if you're
competitive.
Well,
no,
so we parsed that off to agreeableness,
so then the question might be,
is there anything left of these so
called intelligences?
Once you control for personality and Iq
and the answer is no.
Nothing,
nothing left of them,
and the people who keep pushing these
ideas keep trying to push them because
they don't like the idea of real
individual differences,
and to me that's just a matter of
sticking your damn head in the sand
because it's obvious here,
you're going to have a child,
you want the child to have an Iq of 65
or 145 decide,
okay,
so you're all going to vote.
Okay.
You think any one of you is going to
vote to have a child with an Iq of 65,
that child is going to have a hard time
developing even linguistic ability.
They're never going to learn to read,
right?
They're never going to leave home in all
likelihood.
So which child are you going to pick?
Well,
so do you believe in intelligence or
not?
Well,
obviously if you have any sense.